[Musique]
pour préparer des smoothies des potages
ou encore de la mayonnaise un bon
mélangeur à main est un essentiel pour
plusieurs cuistots sa grande qualité
c'est de pouvoir faire des petits
quantités
notre expert Frédéric Chabot a testé 10
mélangeurs à main dont 200 fils leur
prix varie entre 50 et 150 dollars je
regarde tout de la forme de la lame
jusqu'à la longueur du fil en plus de
l'évaluation de caractéristiques comme
la puissance et la solidité des
appareils notre expert a évalué la
performance des mélangeurs à main par
une série de tests
[Musique]
essentiellement on ce qu'on veut c'est
que quand je bois un potage quand je
bois un smoothie quand je mélange une
pâte faut que ça se fasse de plus
rapidement possible et de la meilleure
qualité possible j'ai pas besoin d'avoir
21 vitesses c'est vraiment pas
nécessaire parce que la plupart du temps
on s'en sert à vitesse rapide tout
l'ensemble de créer un vortex il faut
ramener les aliments vers la lame à
chaque fois il est fabriquant
recommandent de jamais l'utiliser
pendant plus que une minute en continu
je connais personne qui limite le temps
d'utilisation de son mélangeur à main
peut-être que le fabricant veut se
protéger j'ai regardé aussi la lame donc
est plus petite lame plate courte
personne un petit peu moins bien
le modèle de Cuisinart muni d'un fil
possède la lame la plus coupante et si
on cherche bien sûr une lame tranchante
le design de la cloche est aussi à
considérer
par les orifices sur le côté tu vas les
aliments vont s'accumuler dans l'orifice
ici et ça va boucher les trous donc ça
boit beaucoup moins bien aussi la très
grande majorité ont cette conception là
ici sur le bug il y aura une conception
différente
nous avons soumis tous les modèles à la
préparation de potage de légumes et de
smoothie
on a choisi des fruits et des légumes
très fibreux donc 60 secondes au
chronomètre c'est parti
une fois qu'ils vont être broyés
puis on va comparer les résidus solide
qui reste
[Musique]
on voit ici avec le calorique les
morceaux de noix de coco sont beaucoup
plus gros contrairement à celui du
brevet aussi c'est vraiment fin donc on
va définitivement que le brevet ici a
mieux performé que le calorique peut
exactement les mêmes ingrédients la même
durée certains appareils faut appuyer
fort et profondément ce qui est vraiment
pas agréable
[Musique]
les deux modèles de marque cuisine art
présentent cette inconvénient
ergonomique alors que d'autres ont une
valeur ajoutée non négligeables c'est le
cas du mélangeur à main Ricardo coup de
coeur pour l'ergonomie de la poignée et
de la gâchette qui contrôle la vitesse
aussi c'est vraiment parfait on a testé
les appareils avec une pâte à pancake
plus épaisse que la pâte à crêpes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà ici on voit que il y a aucune
accumulation un petit peu ici sur la
tige mais c'est tout certains appareils
qui ont des plus grosses cloches la
farine a tendance à s'accumuler un petit
peu sur le dessus c'est un peu moins
pratique
certains appareils ont une cloche avec
une protection en plastique pour pas
écraser c'est très utile si l'échelons
sont recouverts par exemple avec un
antiadhésif les gobelets qui
accompagnent les mélangeurs sont
différents d'une compagnie à l'autre
cependant une fois les tests terminés
notre expert a remarqué bon nombre
dégratignures au fond du gobelet de
starfrites ça m'inquiète un petit peu de
savoir si un peu de plastique qui
pourrait se retrouver dans les aliments
qu'on mange
j'ai peur qu'il y a des éclaboussures
des petites quantités comme ça non
pour la préparation d'une mayonnaise six
appareils ont fait un bon travail les
autres ont nécessité une motion de
brassage supplémentaires il y a certains
appareils qui ont un bouton de sûreté
pour pas partir l'appareil par accident
les modèles à batterie bien sûr sont
toutes équipées de ce système là pour
pas qu'ils se mettent en marche dans le
tiroir par accident j'arrive vraiment
aimer que les mélangeurs sans fil
personne très bien c'était mon rêve
malheureusement
c'est pas les appareils qui performent
le mieux
la moitié des mélangeurs à maintester
est accompagnée d'accessoires fouet
hachoir ou spiraleur honnêtement quand
j'ai vu les accessoires qui venaient
avec ça j'avais un préjugé négatif mais
en général les performances sont quand
même très bonnes la question qu'il faut
se poser c'est vraiment
utile c'est vraiment pratique
finalement notre expert recommande trois
modèles le Brown le Breville et malgré
son gobelet de mauvaise qualité
l'appareil star frites remplissait
fonctions c'est vraiment un des moins
chers qui performe quand même très bien
mais il vient avec un spiraleur ai-je
besoin d'un spiraleur si je veux avoir
un appareil avec des accessoires le
Breville est un excellent choix le Brown
est légèrement supérieur performe
vraiment mieux celui qui vraiment donne
les meilleurs résultats en termes de
texture lorsque je veux mettre un
produit en purée en termes de mélange de
vitesse d'ergonomie de vortex le gobelet
qui vient avec est un bon format aussi
[Musique]